l'Union était européenne et pionnière
dans la régulation des du numérique avec
la législation sur les services
numériques nous avons rendus illégal en
ligne ce qui est illégal hors ligne et
nous avons soumis les géants du Net type
Google Amazon Facebook Instagram à de
nouvelles obligations pour assurer que
nos entreprises et nos citoyens puissent
être en sécurité en ligne oui nous avons
des règles fortes uniques mais une
priorité demeure mettre fin à la loi du
plus fort
que dire oui nous avons la lutte contre
le cyber-harcèlement est une urgence car
nous sommes face à de véritables
tragédies que nous découvrons trop tard
que dire aux enfants harceler à l'école
et dans le calvaire continue à la maison
sur internet que faire pour les
adolescents qui peuvent être menacés
insultés sur les réseaux sociaux
victimes de chantage mis en scène dans
des deep fake pornographiques comme ça
arrive à de nombreuses scrimeuses de
jeux vidéo enfin que répondre aux
parents madame Fox merci pour votre
initiative que dire aux parents dans les
enfants ont décidé de mettre fin à leurs
jours à cause du cyber-harcèlement il
nous faut maintenant passer d'un état de
fait à un état de droit cela passe par
une volonté forte une volonté européenne
car c'est harcèlement ne connaît pas de
frontières où il faut renforcer le
digital services il faut sensibiliser
dès le plus jeune âge aux conséquences
du cyber-harcèlement il faut avoir une
attention
particulière aux jeunes filles et
surtout rester à l'écoute de
l'innovation et se préparer aux diverses
formes de harcèlement qui arriveront
notamment dans le cas du metavère ces
défis appellent une stratégie européenne
forte à laquelle nous devons veiller
pour protéger nos enfants merci beaucoup